i hope it's a good sign it's it's become
boring to me
i don't really want to keep watching
this
it was fun for a few days because it was
like new and interesting but it's really
become
to be honest dull
and people's takes are are already
becoming circular you've heard them they
keep you know
you know
you know i'm getting wary of the
sing-songy [ __ ] on one side about
how like
zilinski and all this stuff like i'm
getting wary of that because that's my
nature to be like wait a minute hold on
where are we going and then on the other
side where people are just literally
putting putin's [ __ ] in their mouth and
sucking them off
on tv is also slightly so i don't know
where i just turn it off
gotta turn it off
you know all these dumb things that we
do you know the you know i was in long
island the other day and there was a
sign you know the town of babylon stands
with ukraine it's like that type of [ __ ]
of course it's like cringe
you look at that stuff you go what the
[ __ ] this gonna do but what else are
we gonna do
what the [ __ ] else are you gonna do you
just go yeah well the town of babylon
stands at ukraine and by the way i've
been in babylon they probably don't
that's the other thing i don't know if i
don't know if they took a poll i don't
know who the [ __ ] put up that sign
but it's just uh
you know i'm getting tired of it
i'm getting tired of it we're supposed
to be out of this
we're supposed to be getting out of a
pandemic
and then there's supposed to be some
type of creative renaissance this is
what i've been
and i don't mean
uh in a good way i mean like a very dumb
silly stupid
uh you know
spate of film projects that come out
where it's like people are like really
goofy and like
nothing has a plot
and everybody just kind of is so happy
to be out of their house and they just
don't you know care
anymore
and um that's what i was picturing not a
a war
we're like in like we're in war mode and
i'm just like i can't
i can't get in i just can't get into it
i can't get into it
does that sound [ __ ] perhaps
but what do you want me to do force it i
can't force it like hbo is forcing the
storyline
i can't force myself into you know we
did it we had the guy on the show and we
listened to david bowie's heroes in the
car and we drove over the 59th street
bridge and then we went to have bagels
we did it
we did what we were there to do
he came on
he told his tale and we supported my
donated 5 000 of bitcoin to him
and uh he sent me a few photos of like
charred russian bodies i guess which i i
wanted photos of something else which i
don't think he got i think it was a
language barrier for five thousand
dollars i wanted other but whatever
doesn't matter we wish him well we wish
him the best but you know we did a
heroic thing for ukraine by having him
on a show
uh you know that's ad supported and we
made a lot of money to do but
i i'm kind of now i've reached the point
now where i go okay i just
i want to you know we're heading into
the spring in the summer and i just you
know we don't need gas being a million
trillion dollars
we just don't need it we don't need it
enough with the sanctions
let's calm down with the sanctions
because here's the deal
it's about to impact all of us in ways
we don't like
airfare going up
price of gas
going up
we're trying to have a summer here
i'm talking like this no one everyone's
afraid to say these things i'm going to
say them
and by the way i don't mean that because
there's a lot of people saying them
by the way it should be taboo like what
i'm saying should be taboo but i believe
it's being pretty openly uh discussed in
congress
but i i i do believe we got to look out
for ourselves a little bit here
and i just think we can't really go too
crazy with the sanctions
what if we did what if we lifted the
sanctions on putin
and said hey
what if
what is it you catch more flies with
honey than you do with vinegar
what if we lifted the sanctions
i mean
as a as a show of good faith
i'm not a geopolitical mastermind
whatever is a show of good faith
lift the sanctions
and go oh hey
do we gotta do
but just you know take care of us here
we need to get the price of fuel
down it's a fact
from new york city
get
how many miles is it from new york city
to the hamptons
how many miles
it is let's see here
sorry
it is exactly 94 miles
okay
it's a hundred miles let's round it okay
it is a hundred miles
of gas how many miles to the gallon are
people getting
on average like
on that highway probably like 18
18 miles to the gallon so how many
gallons of gas about five or six we're
looking at about five or six gallons and
and gas is what now
uh
about four i mean it's about four
yeah people are bracing for five that's
what's coming so every time we go to
hampton's about 30 bucks
yeah five gallons there five gallons
back you're looking at sixty yeah that's
sixty dollars for one trip to the
hamptons
sixty dollars
now that's for the people that drive
then we have helicopters
we have private planes yes no i mean
this is no you're right hey here's the
reality here
no this is i'm not
i'm not
here
to pretend
that things aren't how they are
this is a big problem heading into the
summer
people are going to want to go to europe
they're going to want to travel i have a
lot of friends
that
are going to be in martha's vineyard
maybe they're gonna be in nantucket
ferries you know what i mean look guys
what are we what
like
are you willing to trade your summer for
ukraine
no no no i'm dead serious are you
willing to trade your summer for the
ukraine
i'm talking about
the summer of love the summer of [ __ ]
covet is finally over
facts mandates have dropped everybo i'm
talking partying outside
i mean eating a [ __ ] that tastes like
peach melba the
summer i'm talking about
warm summer breezes
i mean are you willing
to not
participate in a lot of those activities
because of the ukraine
and
i don't know i don't think i am
so i believe right now
we need to lift all the sanctions on
putin
until the fall
because
and and he'll still be there we can
sanction him in the fall i
i just let's be honest
you know
where were you going to go this summer
carviv
is that where you were going to go
were you going to go to carve
were you
or are you going to go to malibu
let's
start looking out
for number one we didn't get to be the
greatest country in the world by taking
care of other people
let's be honest
and maybe you might not believe
we're the greatest country in the world
that's absolutely fine
but we didn't get here
by concern for others
as twitter will tell you
so it's time to stop pretending that we
have we gotta cut it out now
cut it out stop the flags
stop the songs stop the song and dance
routine
cut it out we've done it now for a week
i know we don't you know our our movies
suck nobody respects us anymore we don't
even put out good [ __ ] everything we
make is horrible every comedian special
that comes out on hbo not all of them
but a lot of them it's just somebody on
a stage talking about how sad they are
without a goddamn joke
the the rest of the world has figured us
out
okay we [ __ ] up we haven't put out a
good movie in a long [ __ ] time
there's not [ __ ] to watch we used to
bomb the hell out of these people rape
and pillage but we used to give them
good [ __ ]
great movies okay ghostbusters and
seinfeld and scent of a woman whatever
they loved it
you know rap music black culture all
these things we exported all over the
world
everything we do now sucks
we don't have any soft power that's
worth a damn
so just shut it down
lift the sanctions on putin lift them on
putin let's have a summer it's time to
have a summer whether you're a poor
piece of [ __ ] trash bag who gets drunk
in a lake or you got a little scratch
and you find your way to one of the
[ __ ] oceans in this country somewhere
whatever not my business
everybody deserves a [ __ ] summer
after the two years we've had and that
involves immediately lifting the
sanctions on vladimir putin i'm sorry
i apologize
but i'm i i there's no other way out
here
lift the [ __ ] sanctions
i'm talking gas
289
not even
let's start cutting deals here's the
deal we're gonna feel bad if we lift the
sanctions we're gonna feel horrible
because he's gonna
use all that money to go in there and i
mean god what he's gonna do but
that's why the gas has to be so cheap
the deal has to be so good
i mean i'm talking about what what can
we get it down to 210
it's gotta be so good
that you're eating that burger and the
summer breeze is hitting me in the face
and everybody's got their tits and dicks
out and everybody's having fun and you
just you don't you feel a little bad but
not that bad because the deal's got to
be good for us to turn
away from this to look away
and remove all sanctions we got to get a
good deal on fuel
good deal
so that we can go have a summer
the world is going to be uninhabitable
in i don't know seven years
enjoy
what you have
enjoy what you have now
so this is my and again it is not
it is not the most you know
you know
it's not a position that makes me proud
that i have it
i'm not proud of it
but
do you see another way out so do you see
another way out of this here's here's
how you see a way out here's why i like
it here's why i like it yeah i like it
here's why i like it because if if
they're gonna occupy for 10 or 15 years
hey we come back in the fall and we
sanction them
or not because we got to do [ __ ] then
too the fall is amazing
people want to do a weekend in the
berkshires yeah listen can we cut it out
with this
stop with this
have a summer
i mean
i mean this is this is what we got to do
this is what we gotta do there's there's
no other way around this here
and this is unfortunate